We spent a good amount of time playing
with what are known as line breakpoints.
We created these by clicking
in the gutter on the line of
code where we wanted to pause
the execution of our application.
But Xcode gives us options to
create other types of useful
breakpoints that are not associated with
any single, particular line of code.
To create them, we'll need to
go to the break point navigator.
And I'll remove this breakpoint for now.
And then we'll want to focus our
attention on this plus sign in the lower
left hand corner.
If we click it, a context menu appears,
allowing us to add exception
breakpoints, open GLES breakpoints,
symbolic breakpoints.
And a test failure breakpoint.
In this course we're going to
focus on only the exception and
symbolic breakpoints.
Because the other two, open GL and test
failure, are more specialized cases.
So let's add an exception breakpoint and
see what happens.
The first that we can see is that Xcode
creates a breakpoint that does not
belong to any single file and
it reads all exceptions.
To show the difference I'll
set a line breakpoint.
You can see how this one belongs
to a file and this one does not.
So like it sounds, this breakpoint can
be triggered by any and all exceptions.
If we right click and
edit this breakpoint,
we can see that the break
option is set to on throw.
Thus, anytime the run time
environment throws an exception,
this breakpoint will be hit.
We could change this to on catch but
let's leave this setting for now.
To demonstrate how this breakpoint's
used I'll go to the breakpoint bug
view controller.
Scroll up to the viewDidLoad and
we'll change the action for
the singleTapRecognizer
from handleSingleTap
to hangleSingleTaps with an S because we
know that that method does not exist.
And this will force
an exception to be thrown.
So let's run the application.
We'll tap in the breakpoint
debugging scene.
So once I've tapped the screen,
we can see that our
breakpoint is being reached.
And it's saying that an unrecognized
selector is being sent to the instance
of a memory address for
a breakpoint bug view controller.
And if I try to continue,
then our application will crash.
And it's terminating on a uncaught
exception of NS exception type.
So let's go ahead and
look at the other options we have.
Let's stop for the exception breakpoint.
So the only thing that's different,
besides the action and options,
which we've seen before,
is this exception option.
And we can set it for a particular
language, like objective C and C++, so
that we only fire on exceptions
triggered in either language.
And that's really it for
exception breakpoints.
You may be wondering to yourself, well,
how is a exception breakpoint useful?
This type of breakpoint can be
extremely useful if your application is
crashing on a particular line of code.
But Xcode and
the stack trace really just aren't
giving you a whole lot of information.
So with an exception breakpoint, you
can pause right before the app crashes,
because say it's not
handling the exception.
And then determine who is
the culprit of the crash.